shout outs to pete man that's a take
down i love that kid man you cannot
[ __ ] love this kid you cannot hate on
it like
you cannot hate on it bro and i'll say
why
he got her to go to staten island bro
that's the most impressive part
that's so wild he said come over
to kim kardashian
that is
a very impressive thing like usually
when you're dating somebody especially
somebody with status yeah you're willing
to accommodate absolutely you're willing
to do whatever absolutely you know what
i mean also shorty's a mom like she got
kids and [ __ ] like that like like how
can i make this easier for you like you
put the kids in bed and then we're gonna
drink around the corner like that's
that's what i'm thinking they're not
that different in age probably got a lot
in common you know what i mean kids and
pete they probably got to watch the same
tv shows all that
so
can you come out to stanford staten
island dog
hey i rented out a rooftop in staten
island that's a baller move son who
gives a [ __ ] give me a basement in
manhattan also cheapest rooftop well
done yeah
like a rooftop in manhattan is going to
be big money you're spending oh yeah
rooftop staten island yeah get a view
get a view of the city right now from
there right yeah
yeah that's true that's true did she
have to take the ferry oh no how funny
would that be that verrazano had to be
if you got to take a ferry that's next
level [ __ ] but you know an interesting
thing about this
is that this is the value of shooting
your shot
so many people sitting here going oh my
god how did this happen
oh my god how did he get kim kardashian
how do you pull this [ __ ] off i'll
tell you how just [ __ ] asking
no one is asking kim kardashian on a
date
people are intimidated by kim kardashian
and if they are it's like stupid sleazy
dms it's not like actually real but the
amount of times that a guy actually
genuinely kicks game to kim kardashian
is so little like really really little
and the dude [ __ ] went for it yeah
and clearly got some game clearly
charming right and was able to pull it
off he also had a previous pedigree
yes
when you qualify you trade the paper
clip for the house you know what i mean
like you just kind of level up inch by
inch yeah yeah they spent a week i mean
you don't just shoot snl on saturday
you're there all week probably 15 hours
i heard she was really leaning in
spending the time there when you know
like all right you give her ten percent
of you on monday another little bit on
tuesday i mean that's why people always
fall in love on sets or at least hook up
yeah now what are the answers just fake
it's fake yeah what are the eyes like
pete davidson makes headlines kim's out
she wants to get back in with someone
that's gonna be on headlines it looks
great for him okay let's just go to
disney together
assumption was it was like
my first assumption is is kim k is going
wow mgk and what's the girl's name
how dare you how dare you forget
megaphones no it's a fire come on that's
on me my bad
no disrespect to megan fox like
she's
on point
but
they're going wow look how much the
tabloids love this relationship
both of them and her sister
her little literal sister is with
[ __ ] travis parker her sisters with
travis parker their relationship it's so
interesting travis parker by himself
nobody really cares about uh what's her
name courtney by herself yeah nobody
really cares about all of a sudden them
together making out in public
the talk of the town yeah we love
relationships for some reason that's
weird we love romance i think especially
like odd couples
odd couples but even the bachelor in the
bachelorette they're not odd these are
like the most normal relatable [ __ ]
people and we watch them religiously
yeah there's something that we want to i
don't know live vicariously through it
we want to see the train wreck we want
to know if they make i don't know what
the [ __ ] it is but we are interested
right by we
i'm not really talking about the people
in this room
but america is interested okay
um
so it would be the perfect situation to
do that it'd be a great way to grab some
clout for both of them and he also fits
the prototype perfectly yeah right sad
boy tattooed like
yeah fixer-upper yeah yeah
so it would be perfect
but i kind of have a feeling
that it might be real
not real like
hey this is gonna be
my next husband or wife thing but more
like hey this would be fun someone's
gotta [ __ ] kim k
you think she doesn't get [ __ ]
yeah do you think she just stops [ __ ]
at 40. yeah yeah someone's got a [ __ ]
yeah yeah pete is really he is a rock
star trapped in a comedian's profession
this guy we talk about eddie being a
rock star back in the day your boy eddie
pete's the closest thing we've had in
terms of rockstar lifestyle right this
guy got [ __ ] tattoos does movies
whenever he wants does tv whenever he
wants [ __ ] everyone
women love him he's just a rock star
living as a comedian yeah
this guy's not he's a rock star dude
yeah nothing about him being a comedian
makes sense him as a rock star makes
[ __ ] sense yeah it is not that he's
not funny but just that life that's a
rock star's life dude yeah hey let me
[ __ ] ariana grande you know what i'm
done with her let me [ __ ] cindy
crawford's daughter you know what i'm
done with her he's just a toy for all
these women now but
it's a ladder yeah
you know what i mean he just kept
climbing up that [ __ ] but it is really
interesting like relationships
are
more valuable than credits
yeah do you know what i mean like
people probably know pete from his
relationships more than they do like 100
sketches or something like that on the
show
and it's really interesting like
if you were a young hollywood celeb
and you were trying to like formulate
your career and find your way to go to
the top it would be way more beneficial
for you to date a person more famous
than you yeah than it would to be in a
movie right yeah you need to be in the
public eye enough
but
people are talking about [ __ ] mgk
non-stop yeah because of the the
relationship with rose and i'm sure he
has an album that's doing good and
people are into the music but the
conversation isn't really about the
music mm-hmm it's what's her name again
megan megan fox
can't i remember her [ __ ] name oh no
doug sounds like i'm hating i'm not
hating i think she's absolutely
beautiful been trapped in that hotel
room that's what i think i have yeah you
got cabin fever she was like a line in a
movie you can't get it right maybe that
was his line megan fox
frozen
up yeah yeah
we got to talk about the fights but like
yeah it's interesting i wonder if like
you're a manager these days and you
start thinking about you know how you
can design
your town's career i think i wonder if
you start thinking about relationships
they've been doing that for years well
tom cruise right yeah yeah who else i
mean little zan came out publicly it was
like yo they set me up with noah cyrus
and i didn't even want to be in this
relationship this is when he was like
going crazy about the label and all that
stuff but like he came out and said it
keep going i don't know a bunch and i
don't know i think that guy shawn mendes
i think they say his relationship is
fake who's that girl oh i forget do a
little yeah
i know a fake relationship that i can't
say but it's hilarious
hilarious
actually matter of fact i'll say it but
i need you to bleep this miles make sure
that you bleep it
right you ready make sure you got this
time okay
[Laughter]
heard that i heard that uh maybe from
you maybe okay we said that maybe but
that is hysterical yeah so funny
it's valuable this relationship [ __ ] is
valuable man and effective
very it's really effective why
i don't know i think it creates like a
new like crossover dynamic it's like
when you do an episode where like they
bring the cast together like a crossover
episode you're like wow these two you
know
ratchet yeah
holy [ __ ] yeah it's like you're tapping
into their fan base yeah you have your
fan base now you're tapping into their
fan base yeah and those fan bases
cross-pollinate and both parties win
yeah and ideally not ideally like
usually it's very rare that you're going
to date someone who has your same fan
base
yeah at least you shouldn't no yeah i
mean if you're doing it if you're doing
it for clout yeah they never do it's
always some odd couple yeah oh that's
why the odd couples work holy [ __ ] yeah
so should we not believe in any of these
i'm looking at an article right now of
top uh
fans thought these uh relationships were
fake and number seven is pete davidson
and kate beckinsale so
people have thought this before about
pete davidson oh yeah
yeah he was with kate because yeah that
was absolutely a piece though yeah yeah
yeah he knows how to pick him if they
are fake
he knows how to pick the fake
relationship i mean like god bless and
also like what are the benefits with it
is it like some green card [ __ ] where
it's like
you you pretend to be married like maybe
sometimes you [ __ ] but it's not an
actual real relationship and then the
person gets the green card and now
you're straight yeah yeah yeah because
i've i've met people that were like that
like started out as a fake relationship
and they just hung out so much so they
could like learn about each other so
they could pass the test right and then
it was like [ __ ] it all right we out
here yeah you know maybe that's what it
is pete might just be super charming
you spent a lot of time with the point
where you know you spent a little time
with him yeah spent a little time with
him on a setup and then you're like you
know what i like this guy yeah i'm in it
i'm in yes
um i don't know what do you think real
or fake
yeah
not really
even if it's not let us play dude i mean
what are you doing no i like this i
think no i'm talking about mark that's
what i'm saying i like i i like the the
august wants to believe like girls
trying to [ __ ] comics he's like yeah
yeah he's like finally we're the rock
stars yeah go get em babe look how lucky
you are see if it wasn't for you i'd be
[ __ ] tim kardashian you're basically
kim kardashian man yeah that's all it is
yeah yeah now i understand your
skepticism i'm usually skeptical of any
hollywood relationship yeah
um
the only reason i was skeptical is
because the picture came out with them
on the roller coaster i was just gonna
say and it's just like
well we're trying to keep this low-key
it's like well why go on the ride that
takes pictures yeah
it's like it's not even paparazzi the
ride is the paparazzi yeah right so you
want that getting out yeah because it
might not even be a picture of you the
other person on that ride with you can
ask for that picture right right they're
in the row three you're in row four and
they get to post it on instagram and
then the story goes wild and it's like
oops we didn't know you can also shut
down the park easily
you know what i mean kim kardashian fall
out boy yeah
yeah maybe it's true love say again
maybe it's true love though who am i to
say i want to go to the wedding if it is
[Applause]